this weekend NPR interviewed
representative Adrian Smith Republican
of Nebraska and as some a gotcha
question is every American entitled to
eat the segment was about cutting food
stamps in NPR's agenda was clear show
the Republicans don't care if Americans
starve which is why they want to cut
food stamps Smith answered well they
nutrition obviously we know is very
important and I would hope that we can
look to it is essential it is a special
this was not enough for the media who
declared Smith had under head after all
doesn't everyone have the right to food
now imagine a land where there is a
right to food housing and health care
imagine that such rights were enshrined
in the constitution of that land that
would mean that everyone in the land
could live free without the burden of
worry over such basic resources right
know the South African Constitution
guarantees a right to all of these
commodities in fact the Constitution
even creates a legal duty for the
government to help secure such
commodities if there are some 11 million
food insecure people in the country
including 1.5 million children with
chronic malnutrition and growth stunting
life expectancy in South Africa is 57
years there are currently 12 million
people in the country without adequate
housing the population of South Africa
is about 55 million people declaring a
commodity a right it is obvious does not
make that commodity materialize and it
certainly doesn't make it materialize in
the most efficient fashion markets make
commodities materialize in the most
efficient fashion in the United States 9
out of 10 Americans live above the
global poverty standard 96 percent of
poor parents say their children were
never hungry in the past year according
to scholars at the Heritage Foundation
and a poor child is more likely to have
a table TV a computer a widescreen
plasma TV and Xbox or a TiVo in the home
than to be hungry even the Department of
Agriculture the government agency
responsible for administration of food
stamps upon which approximately 15% of
Americans now rely admit that well under
6 percent of American households have to
worry even about decreased calorie
consumption we want to know what fills
the gap for Americans when they're poor
feeding America a private charity that
receives 900 million dollars per year in
food donations the vast bulk from
private companies in fact there is a
strong link between food stamps and
obesity so is America worse off than
South Africa despite our Constitution
not mandating food is right of course
not
we're significantly better off because
it turns out that using government to
confiscate wealth from the very people
who produce cheaper and more plentiful
ends up exacerbating scarcity declaring
things right it feels good when those
rights come with forced redistribution
ISM the things become less available so
no you don't have a right from the
government to food you have the freedom
from government to live in a country or
food is available in plenty and where
your fellow Americans help pick you up
when you are down I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show I hope everybody
had a wonderful Memorial Day weekend I
hope that you took a few minutes to pay
honor and tribute to the men and women
who have sacrificed their lives lay down
their lives for the freedoms that we now
enjoy obviously that's a sacrifice we
can never live up to but that doesn't
stunt our ability to try or relieve us
of our ability to try I want to talk a
little bit about President Trump
Memorial Day which I thought was
actually quite wonderful and I also want
to talk about the the breaking scandal
maaan scandal of Jared Kushner and all
of that but first I want to say thank
you to our friends over at helix sleep
our sponsors over at helix league so
this is the best mattress that I have
ever slept on so helix sleep the way
that this works you go to helix sleep
calm /ban they give you a survey as to
which should you like to lie on your
side you like to lie on your stomach
when you sleep you lie on your back you
like the mattress to be firmer or suffer
do you like it to be kind of heat
absorbent or do you like it to be cool
well after you do that they develop a 3d
bio bio mechanical model of your body
through their proprietary algorithms
they've developed with the world's
leading ergonomics and biomechanics
expert and they give you the most
comfortable mattress you have ever slept
on this entity in a box you open up the
box you enroll it and immediately
inflates because it is a foam mattress
and and then you just put it on your bed
and if you don't like it you can try it
for a hundred nights if you don't like
it you can send it right back to them
and they'll give you a 100% refund I
promise you your end up using it helix
customers report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality I love my helix
sleep mattress my wife loves the helix
sleep mattress and we also you can get a
helix sleep mattress that actually has
separate settings for both sides of the
bed so if you and your spouse do not
enjoy sleeping on the same type of
mattress then helix sleep can fix that
for you as well go to helix sleep comm
slash men you get $50 off your order
it's also a lot cheaper than it would a
lot more inexpensive than it would be if
you bought one of these really really
expensive mattresses from the mall so
you go to helix sleep comm slash
spending a 50-person $50 off your order
$50 off your order at helix sleep
dot-com / Ben again that helix sleep HDL
IX sleep calm / bed needs that / Ben's
that they know that we sent you so
president Trump spent Memorial Day the
way that the president is supposed to
spend Memorial Day honoring the fallen
so he went over to Arlington National
Cemetery and there he gave what I
thought was quite a wonderful speech and
it is a market difference when when
Trump talks about the military and I
think this is why so many people
resonate to trump and resonated to him
during the general election when Trump
talks about the military there's a
marked warmth there this is a guy who
likes the military this is a guy who has
respect for the military it's somebody
who sees the military as the leading
edge of American power and American
goodness and decency as opposed to
President Obama who always seemed a bit
discomforted with with the American
military he always seemed like somebody
who was uncomfortable with American
military power somebody who is
uncomfortable around soldiers and
members of other members of military the
same thing with Hillary Clinton who
reportedly back in the 90s actually
asked if there was a way that she could
prevent people from wearing the uniform
in the White House I was according to a
couple of people who worked in the White
House at the time Trump obviously has a
lot of warmth or the military in that
show died Memorial Day which is quite
wonderful here was president from
speaking yesterday about the sacrifice
made and by the Fallen letters also
pledged to tell the stories of Robert
Chris Andrew and all of America's fallen
warriors today and for the next 1,000
years and he spoke I thought in in
really glowing terms out the military it
was really quite wonderful
he also marked his first Memorial Day as
commander-in-chief by heading through
the throngs of motorcycles participating
in Rolling Thunder the Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson
also was part of Rolling Thunder and he
he delivered a tribute he called service
members angel sent us by God he said to
every gold star family god is with you
and your loved ones are with him
they died in war so that we could live
in peace every time you see the Sun Rise
over this blessed land please know that
your brave sons and daughters pushed
away the night and delivered for us for
all of us that great and glorious dawn
pretty good stuff and again this is one
of the reasons I think why President
Trump is I think this is why President
humph is is there's a certain gut level
Americanism that people people resonate
to in Trump if the things about America
that I think Trump doesn't understand
but I think he does understand gut level
patriotism there's a great picture of
Trump hugging a six year old born in
Christian Jacobs he's dressed like a
Marine because his father who's a Marine
Sergeant Christopher Jacobs was killed
during a training accident in California
in 2011 and the you won't see any of
this on the news by the way the media
refused to cover anything that Trump
does that's unifying or nice and this
was unifying and nice and good for
President Trump for doing it the other I
thought great tribute to the military
came from an active do or a former
active duty military guy was active duty
until five minutes ago
General James Madison who of course is
the Secretary of Defense he was asked
over the weekend on one of the news
shows about what keeps him awake at
night now normally when members of the
administration you know Obama Trump
anybody else when they're asked what
keeps them awake at night they talk
about Russia they talk about Isis they
talk about all the various threats in
the world this is a stellar answer what
keeps you awake at night nothing I keep
other people awake at night and it's
very pretty amazing pretty amazing I
love that so basically it was him
channeling Bryan Cranston from Breaking
Bad he is the one who knocks pretty
spectacular stuff well here's the thing
Trump has the capacity to unify he does
if he would just you know pay attention
to pay attention to policy if you just
buckle down to patriotic rallies go out
there this is why I think on his foreign
trip he gained some points in the
estimation of the American public
because he didn't represent America
badly he went out there and he was fine
he was fine I mean there are a lot of
people in the media who are very upset
about him like pushing the the president
of Estonia I guess out of the way or
doing this kind of weird handshake with
Emmanuel macron as the president of
France but in essence Trump was fine
abroad and the despite the media's best
efforts to paint him as some sort of
idiot who's going to make America love
flourish and terrible on the world stage
we'll talk about Europe's reaction to
Trump in just a second because it's
actually Europe that's being really
stupid and we'll talk about that in a
second but the point I'm making here is
that Trump is still a president with
potential at this point in time Bill
Clinton had a lower approval rating than
Donald Trump does so Trump still has the
potential to turn this thing around in
order for him to turn this thing
found though he's going to need to start
acting in ways that aren't vague what I
mean by that is that the big controversy
over the weekend was this controversy
over Jared questioner Jared Kushner is
of course from son-in-law Jared Kushner
really has no business being part of the
government I mean I'm sorry bricks folks
but Jared Kushner is not qualified to be
in government he spent no time at all in
his life thinking about government
thinking about governance
he is a stop guys stock market Wall
Street guy who happens to be married to
the president's daughter and sudden he's
in charge of Middle East peace the
opioid crisis the infrastructure plan
and all these other things Trump doesn't
want to deal with again if Hillary
Clinton is done the same thing with
Chelsea's husband we'd all be saying
this is ridiculous in every sense of the
word Trump has given all this power to
Jared and now Jarrod got Trump sort of
in trouble because there are all these
stories breaking over the weekend I want
if he construct them and break them down
because the media is making more of them
than they are but Trump should still
move on beyond Jared Kushner who is a
New York leftist who has no business in
government so here is what broke over
the weekend on Thursday NBC News
reported that Jared Kushner was subject
of scrutiny in the FBI's ongoing Russia
probe we talked about this on Thursday
it makes no difference because again
there's no element that says that he's
actually guilty of anything at this
point so so what okay so he's so they're
looking at him not a big deal then on
Friday the Washington Post drops a
bombshell right they report that Kushner
and the Russian ambassador circuitously
Atkins slate has a good rundown of this
their real leftist but this is basically
just straight reporting they reported
that Kushner and Russian ambassador
circuitously act discussed setting up a
secret communications back channel
between the Trump transition scene team
and the Kremlin in December in March the
White House said the two had met but the
post sources say the FBI took an
interest in what was discussed and then
apparently right after that Kushner had
a meeting with the head of a Russian
Putin run bank basically right about the
same time the detail in The Washington
Post report that's damning is that they
were setting up back channels lots of
presidents set up back channels with
other countries for negotiation purposes
because they don't want every
negotiation to be out in the open it's
important you'll be able to pick up the
phone and have talks with people but one
of the more nefarious ones that should
have drawn more scrutiny was in 2008
Barack Obama set up a back-channel with
the Iranian government which really
should have drawn scrutiny should have
prevented him from being elected if we
didn't have our heads up our butts but
you know the back channels are certainly
common
in American politics the problem with
this back channel is that according to
the Washington Post and this is under
dispute now Fox News said that it didn't
really go down this way the New York
Times said it couldn't confirm the
Washington Post sticks by its reporting
the White House has not denied this
Kushner apparently asked the Russian
ambassador kiss lyac if the back-channel
could involve him walking over to the
Russian embassy and speaking in person
to kiss lyac and using basically methods
of communication from the Russian
embassy back to Vladimir Putin now that
is actually suspicious so if that's true
that's a problem why would you want to
set up what is basically what they call
a skiff which is a secure secure
compartmentalized area where
intelligence can't get in why would you
do that from the Russian embassy why
would you want to say that the Russian
KGB the FSB why would you why wouldn't
you want the effort why would you want
to set the FSB could monitor your
communications or the NSA could not that
is suspicious and that's a problem but
again that has not been confirmed and
their suspicion that maybe the Russians
are leaking that out there just to make
trouble so we don't have confirmation on
that it is notable the White House has
not formally denied that yet
then on Saturday reuters reported
Kushner had made undisclosed contacts
with Kiselyov between April and November
of last year its sources said that to
discuss terrorism and economic relations
between the US and Russia on Sunday the
New York Times reported that Kushner was
among the voices pushing Trump to fire
James Comey and Monday The New York
Times reported that Kushner met in
December with Putin associate Sergei
Gourcuff who was the head of that
Russian bank I was talking about subject
to US sanctions in the interest of
establishing a back-channel with the
Kremlin
that's a weird report also because
Gourcuff is not a political actor he's
actually just a financial actor so
that's a very weird way of setting up a
back-channel since the way the
back-channel was set up that's a little
bit suspicious and the fact that they
didn't report any of these contacts in
the first place which they could have
done in confidential classified settings
now the answer to this is basically one
of two things one is they were setting
up some sort of back-channel because
they don't trust American intelligence
not to leak
that's quasi fair considering that
American intelligence has been
unbelievably leaky ever since Trump took
office it's also a little bit suspicious
again because the people at intelligence
whatever you also you say about them
David French make this point at least
they take an oath to protect and defend
the Constitution you can't say the same
about the FSB if you're talking about
people in the
various beliefs in nefarious intent I go
FSB before CIA but defense number one is
that depends number two is just
ignorance that Jared didn't know what he
was doing he wanted to set up a secure
back-channel where he couldn't be
monitored and so he walked into the
Russian embassy and wanted something
done there and he proposed this kind of
off the top of his head because you
dum-dum that is possibility number two
and possibility number three is that
there's actual corruption going on so
here's the way that's played out over
the weekend James clapper the former
head of the CIA under President Obama he
he is said over and over and over he has
no evidence of collusion between the
Trump team and the Russians but he says
a warning light was on regarding Russian
collusion but just from a theoretical
standpoint I will tell you that my
dashboard warning light was clearly on
and I think that was the case with all
of us the intelligence community very
concerned about the nature of these
approaches to the Russians okay so
that's the one that the left is Lee is
leaning on the right is leaning on the
fact he says he has no evidence of
collusion both can be true you can be
suspicious and you can also say there's
no evidence as of yet
General John Kelly is the head of the
Department of Homeland Security and he
said that no one should be worried about
setting up these back channels everybody
has back channels what's the big deal
anyway that you can communicate with
people particularly organizations that
are maybe not particularly friendly to
us is a good thing and again it comes
back to whatever the communication is
comes back into the government and
shared across the government so it's
it's a it's not a bad thing to have
multiple communication lines to any
government okay but then he was asked
well how about using the Russian embassy
and you didn't really have a great
answer to that we'll get to some more
reactions the Kushner story and what I
really think is going on in just second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at legacy box so as I say
frequently preserving your memories is I
think one of the most important things
that you can do my wife and I take tons
of pictures of our kids we have lots of
old video my parents have lots of old
video of us and that's why my parents
have been using legacy box to send
material to legacy box we take your old
films all your old pictures
all your old reels your old tapes you
send them from from YouTube legacy backs
into legacy box you slap a barcode on
each of those pieces and then they
compile all of that into a DVD or a
thumb drive so you have all of it
available at a minute to notice you
don't have to worry about schlepping
boxes out of the house in case of an
emergency
instead he just got a thumb drive or you
got it on your computer which is awesome
legacy boxes take care takes care of
everything and it provide updates at
every step that's what those barcodes
are for so they can scan those in you
can tell where each piece of your
memorabilia is in the process over a
quarter million families have used them
already for a limited time you get a
legacy voxcom right now / been legacy
box comm / been and you get a 40%
discount on your orders already great
price and now you get a 40% discount
when you go to legacy box comm / been
great Father's Day gift
legacy box comm / been again legacy
box.com / been make sure you preserve
all of your memories and it makes a
fantastic Father's Day gift or Mother's
Day gift or birthday gift it's a
fantastic product okay so meanwhile so
basically the left is saying that
Kushner is obviously colluding and the
right is saying well no channels of
communication have been a way of doing
business for a long time Charles
Krauthammer has a different take he says
there's no reason to trust the story in
the first place I mean what if it's the
Russians who are leaking it just to make
trouble well I want Lindsay here I don't
trust the story
the Russians are leaking it clearly on a
channel they know we're going to pick up
the Russians are masters of
disinformation they already had
Washington with its knickers in a twist
over the Russia conspiracy this is an
added twist somebody's going to get a
hernia here I think I'll stop the
metaphor if you would point but we have
no idea if it's true let's say it is
true isn't the problem here the
accusation here that there was some
collusion during the campaign with the
Russians
well everyone agrees if the story is
true it occurred after the campaign
during the transition so unless there's
some nefarious connection here there's
no connection to the what was alleged to
have happened
the campaign and lastly we've had
back-channel connections with
adversaries for generations Henry
Kissinger had them with the Russians and
the Chinese Hillary had a back-channel
to establish the opening of negotiations
with the Iranians in what ended up is
the Iranian nuclear deal and Barack
Obama with Cuba it's absolutely not yet
and the negotiations with Canada
occurred in secret in occurred in Canada
in secret our negotiations with the
Cubans this happens all the time
I don't quite understand where's the
crime other than it's another piece that
has Russia and the headline Trump people
in the headline and thus it's supposed
to be scandalous show me okay and I I
agree with Krauthammer I don't see what
scandalous about the story it's not
really standing up to scrutiny over time
however I do want to talk about why it
is that Americans are drawing such
divergent conclusions from the hit
behavior of the Trump administration and
how Trump can help cure that some of
this is the media and the media are now
we're going to let go of it but I'll
talk about what Trump can do to get past
this because it will dog him regardless
of who you blame it's going to continue
to dog him until we come to some sort of
realistic conclusion on all of this so
in order for you to care about that
though you're going to have to go to
daily wire calm right now become a
subscriber so for $8 a month you can go
over to daily wire calm and you become a
subscriber if you're a daily if you're
already a normal subscriber getting an
annual subscription then not only will
you still have access to the rest of the
live show and be part of the mailbag and
be part of Andrew Clemens mailbag see
the rest of his live show we're gonna be
adding new material in the coming months
it's going to be really stellar those
you come in the annual subscriber right
now you get a free signed copy of a book
I wrote with my dad say it so Papa Dada
me and the 2005 Chicago White Sox
championship season brand-new book from
me and my dad all about fathers and sons
and baseball my dad and I are both huge
baseball fans perfect Father's Day gift
for your dad annual subscription at
daily wire and you get a free signed
copy I will sign it for you and I can
promise you it's a really fun book store
it's a great book and again even if you
don't love baseball I think that the the
father-son stuff in there is really it's
actually kind of moving so you should
pick up a copy but you can only do that
as an annual subscriber over at daily
wire.com we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
you